Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU-chan, you're singing.
Ruffians!
Today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for waking up early and for joining us today for our 72nd episode!
I get it why Moco-chan always says things wrong.
70 seconds doesn't sound right.
That's too big of a number, no?
I agree.
Thank you for being here with us this morning, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians who maybe, you're waking up for the first time!
And joining us, uh, waking up for the first time!
To join us for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Today is the first morning!
Not like that.
Happy birthday!
BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Now Ruffians, you didn't know, but...
Happy birthday!
It's your first morning.
Or the alternative is that maybe there's some vampiric Ruffians out there and this is the first morning they're spending with us.
Huh?
Like vampires, they don't live... Vampires don't live in the morning time, Moco-chan.
That's weird.
I don't think we have any vampire Ruffians.
So it's a key!
Well... I... Maybe you wanna be a vampire!
Because... It might be handy... Since there was another Pero Sighting... Be handy if you're a vampire!
Then you could...
You could... drink up... Pero... blood? That's not what I was thinking. I was just thinking "maybe Pero is afraid of vampires." But I guess if you wanna have Pero's blood. It's basically a juice box. I guess anything's a juice box if you're a vampire but---
Pero Sighting! De-den! Oh!
Did, uh... Did something happen when you were downloading some DLC for The Sims?
Are you sure this is what you wanted?
It looks kinda cool, but... Yeah, there's a lot of cool Sims stuff, right?
Pero looks... pretty angry here, huh?
You didn't do something that maybe warranted this.
Right?
Ha!
Well, but, you know, Sims can be really fun, you know.
You can be really creative, but it's kinda good just as it is too, right?
You know, maybe that's why Pero's upset, you know.
He maybe just wants you to enjoy the base game just as it is, you know?
Like rice without toppings, you know?
You know the rice is delicious, but if you put a bunch of things on top, then you might miss out on the complicated flavors that the rice has to offer.
Yeah, complicated flavors of the rice.
Get it?
You get it right.
I know recently Kiara-senpai and Nerissa, they play The Sims.
And I look pretty fine, huh?
It did.
Huh.
Is that why Awaken learns to play The Sims on you, maybe?
I kind of felt something a bit too low.
Not allowed.
BAU BAU!
Well, I guess good luck trying to fix things now, huh?
Good luck!
BAU BAU!
That would be really scary to have on your computer all the time.
You just wake it up and Pero's there!
But it's trapped, right?
Pero's always moving, right?
So... Maybe he's trapped, but temporarily.
Temporarily, huh?
Well, on the topic of temporary... Ruffians!
For a while there, we really weren't sure about this one.
But... It looks like finally... FUWAMOCO!
We're able to log into the EMPOWER server!
BAU BAU!
You know, we had so much fun playing with Advent last week.
And we really wanted to play it again.
But you know, it seems like there's a number of server issues and we just couldn't log in.
We couldn't.
Yeah, but you know, it can't really be helped because it's just such an explosively popular game right now.
It makes sense.
It happens.
But, uh, well we mentioned it earlier, right?
But... Now!
Officially!
We will be playing Power World on Thursday!
On Thursday.
Yeah.
So... Sorry, Bread and Fred.
BAU BAU.
We couldn't play Bread and Fred, but... We'll see you again sometime soon.
It'll happen in the future.
Bread and Fred will be there.
Yeah.
For Power World.
Power World.
We hope that we can catch a lot of the cute pals and figure out some of the main mysteries, you know, of the game.
Maybe we can play with some of our senpai too!
There's a lot we still have to learn, but I'm looking forward to it!
Now we don't have to be envious and go to Mana-chan.
Mana-chan, I want to play POWER.
Can we play Power Up?
I wanna play Power Up.
Use the puppy dog eyes.
Power Up.
Please.
Right!
We're looking forward to it on Thursday!
BAU BAU!
Exciting, right, Ruffians?
Well, you know we're talking about all the mysteries of our world, but...
There's been some other mysteries we've been dealing with, huh?
There has been.
Well, Ruffians, do you remember that one FUWAMOCO Morning where our audio was suddenly very different from how it was beforehand?
Do you?
Yeah.
It was really surprising for us.
It was!
Yeah.
Ever since then, you know, we've been having some weird audio issues where everything is rather subdued in volume compared to our older streams.
Really, really, really, we absolutely didn't touch anything.
No!
But something somewhere must have gone funny.
Yeah.
But,
Finally!
It seems like things might be a little better now.
Yeah.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Huh?
Is it a little bit more like what it used to be closer to debut?
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
We tried really hard to figure out the mystery causing the issue.
But we're still not sure what happened.
But you know, as long as it's better!
Right!
It sounds the same!
The same as... Older streams.
BAU!
You know...
That is two of us, and you know, we've talked about that.
Because of that, things are really different for us compared to our senpai.
And, well, that can be really inconvenient sometimes.
You know, there's no one we can go to for help.
No Mane-chan.
Yeah.
BAU BAU.
But, you know, so because of that, you know, we just have to do our best.
We gotta do our absolute best.
And you know, part of that, a big part of that is definitely try not to play around with things unnecessarily when they're working.
Yeah.
The whole thing has been a bit of an ordeal.
Let us know if you think it's better, okay, Ruffians?
We didn't do anything.
It's fixed, though.
It is fixed.
Right.
Well, we're always looking to improve, so... BAU BAU!
It is better.
It's probably good.
Everyone has different ears, you know.
Right?
But...
Well, we're gonna do our best to find something that works for as many Ruffians as possible.
It might break again.
It's a mystery, we don't know why.
It's still a mystery!
But Ruffians will actually...
Something a bit surprising yesterday.
You know, we had a members stream where we tidied up our download folder and we chatted about a bunch of different things.
And, well, this time we got a little passionate about, well... Maybe something we shouldn't have.
Something...
Well, our opinions on food.
Somehow, we ended up talking about what is the most delicious part of the leaf of lettuce.
Quite in-depth.
In-depth!
Yum!
I know.
We wanted to apologize.
You know, Zatsudan... Just chatting and whatnot.
Yeah, it's definitely something you know when you talk about a lot of different things.
But, talking about things like this... I don't know if that's acceptable, Ruffians.
So, we wanted to say that we're sorry.
We're sorry for talking about lettuce.
Yeah.
We'll make sure that we're talking about more wordy topics in the future.
And not about how the deep green of the chlorophyll tastes delicious like the taste of fresh nature.
Yeah.
Not that stuff.
No.
And we'll also make sure not to hate on nice breakfast foods like cereal or pancakes either.
Right, Moco-chan?
I'll do my best.
You know, I definitely don't feel passionate when it comes to breakfast foods, okay?
That means you do though, right?
BAU BAU!
Not natto.
Ah, not natto.
No.
BAU BAU!
This is my apology.
We just apologized!
Apology accepted!
Thank you!
Ruffians!
Okay, this is silly, but we have something to talk about.
Okay?
Sometimes, in the hololive reddit,
Do you have any clue what it could be, Ruffians?
Hi.
Oh no, Scarlet.
I'm asking you a question.
You stay put.
You are being interrogated right now.
You stay here.
Hi.
I'm not seeing any answers.
Well, I'll just have to tell you then, hi.
Wow.
It seems like some Ruffians think that we have some kind of method or complicated system behind the times when we accidentally think what we say.
Except, no.
They don't think it's an accident thing.
They think that it's coordinated, okay?
I, Ruffians, you do realize that
It's embarrassing for us.
We honestly don't try to say things at the same time.
We definitely don't plan for it or have a system or use things like hand signals or anything like that to do that.
That's so silly!
Think about what you're saying!
Right!
Yeah, I know, you know, it might be hard because you don't have a twin.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I'm sorry to break it to you.
It just, it just happens.
You know?
It's actually harder for us to sync up if we're trying to count down to sync at the same time.
Like, okay Moco-chan.
Three, two, one.
We are FUWAMOCO!
See, it's better like... We are FUWAMOCO!
Also doesn't help that we're laughing, huh?
Ah, laughing doesn't help, huh?
But you see!
Yeah.
You know, I think for us, we're just used to how each other breathes.
And then from there it's easy.
Does that make sense?
Right.
Maybe it's just that our breathing and our speech patterns are similar?
Point proven.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
We know how each other's brains work, and we know what will come up next.
All right.
Nerissa, you want to sync up with FUWAMOCO?
Have we known already?
I made a sync up.
Huh?
I did.
Yeah.
But I did a video editing.
Oh.
You will be the triplet!
Well, Ruffians, you know, I know it's weird and maybe it's hard to understand, so we're sorry, okay?
But you know, this is just what being a twin is about.
It's a part of it.
At least for us.
Got it!
Yeah, we definitely don't plan to say things like a whole sentence together.
I think one time we synced up talking about parts of an anison sandwich.
That is not something we planned to do!
You didn't really talk about it.
One side being one part of an anison sandwich.
It doesn't happen.
Okay?
It's just...
Something, okay?
Maybe it's just FUWAMOCO being FUWAMOCO.
Sorry!
BAU BAU!
BAU!
Is it silly?
It's just FUWAMOCO.
Ruffians!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we've been working pretty hard this week.
And I think that you've been working even harder too.
You know, maybe it's been a little rough, so... Moco-chan!
Do you have anything that you could say to make it a little less rough for the Ruffians?
Well...
Ruffians!
It's today!
Today is the day again where it's time to listen up because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me.
Mococo!
Ruffians!
Hi there.
Good morning!
How are you feeling today?
Uh-uh.
A bit tired.
Good morning.
Sleepy?
Well, you know.
That makes sense.
You know, you keep on working so hard every day!
I think sometimes it's hard to see yourself improving and growing little by little.
But if you focus, you know, it's there!
I know it is!
You're moving forward each and every day thanks to the effort of your own hard work.
And even though not many people might recognize your efforts, you know that in your heart, you're doing it.
And I do too, okay?
So just continue to do your best,
Just believe in your process, and I'm sure it'll all work out, okay?
And you know, if one door does close, another door will open.
Believe in yourself and all your strengths, because you're amazing!
I know you are.
Fuwawa knows you are.
And even Pero, he knows too.
Everything is gonna be okay.
Even if it's a bit rough right now, okay?
You can do it.
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
You can do it, Moco!
It's okay!
BAU BAU!
Well, let's check out who's the Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... BAU BAU!
Morning!
Birdie!
Kinda sounds like body.
Birdie's my body.
Look at those ears too!
The ears are big like mine.
What is Birdie looking at though?
See, that's a deep mystery.
Ruffians!
Mysterious Deep Eyes.
Do you have any ideas what birdie's looking at?
She's looking at a birdie.
At a birdie?
No.
Huh?
A demon of sound birdie?
Or... Whoa.
G-g-ghost!
Ghost!
A-a train?
I don't know.
Hello.
Looking at FUWAMOCO!
With those eyes.
Hi.
A bug?
Maybe like a stink bug?
I don't like that.
That one makes sense.
Wow, Moco-chan, how does birdie BAU BAU?
I think birdie goes...
Wow, I was thinking the exact same BAU BAU.
A bit white.
A little bit BAU BAU.
A bit... Scary.
Yeah.
Sounds a bit scary.
Well, you know, when there's a deep mystery in front of you.
Right, it can be a bit spooky.
BAU BAU
Well, you know, Birdie is an absolute cutie.
Also, maybe has a bit of a lazy side sometimes.
That's okay.
Yeah, but that's okay because Birdie just wants to snuggle up with you.
It's okay to be lazy if you're gonna snuggle.
Yeah.
Is it awkward?
It's only awkward if you wanted to be Ruffians.
Well, it's okay.
Because birdie is cute.
Yeah.
It's okay.
It's forgiven.
Because birdie is cute.
BAU BAU!
What do you mean ha?
What?
It makes sense.
The logic is there.
Thank you, birdie.
We learned a lot today.
BAU BAU!
Well, next we have... Today I went on a walk!
And we have... De-den!
Oh my gosh!
That's both beautiful and super cold!
I can feel the cold air rushing through my body just looking at this!
That's the sound.
But the trees look so pretty too!
We hope you had a wonderful walk and or ski!
Is this also another time where it's okay to be lazy if we're going to cuddle?
Because it's chilly!
Oh, well, you should probably find somewhere like a lodge or something with a
What are you imagining now, huh?
Moco-chan, you suggested we snuggle in the snow.
I was just thinking.
Well, thank you for sharing your view with us too!
BAU BAU!
I don't know snuggling in the snow is the safest idea.
A snow cave.
Well, our Question of the Day we have... De-den!
During the reveal, Fuwawa let us know that the New Year outfits have paw beans.
We do, we have paw beans!
Yeah, it feels nice squishing cats' or dogs' beans, so I wanted to ask, is it okay to touch FUWAMOCO's paw beans?
Touch our beans.
Only when we say it's okay.
Okay.
Permission.
But actually, you know, it would be really nice to get a hand massage.
Right?
Sometimes you see them on TV, right?
It's so fancy and all!
A little aggressive, no?
Why?
Take your heart and go... No, resting the paw is softening the bean.
It sounds good right now, too hot.
But!
Only when we say so.
Got it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions, for always being a big part of FUWAMOCO Morning.
Please don't forget, we want to see what walks you're going on.
We want your burning questions.
Please let us know what doggies you've been seeing.
Who's your doggie?
And, well, if you happen to see Pero, you should probably report it. Report the Sighting to us.
We're always waiting so please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING and journalism.
Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO Scoop, okay?
Don't forget.
BAU BAU!
And as for our next stream, we have...
De-den!
Surprise!
Well, we don't have a stream on our channel tonight, but we'll be seeing you over on the official hololive English YouTube channel with some very important information.
Upcoming hololive Expo and Fifth Fest Capture the Moment!
Are you excited, Ruffians?
I'm so excited!
But there will be some more details as well as some cool news revealed!
And it will all be in English, so please join us for it, okay?
It'll be a lot of fun together with Ina-senpai and Rin-senpai!
I'm excited!
Don't forget, okay?
Just because it's not on FUWAMOCO's channel, okay?
BAU BAU!
And for our schedule!
Let's take a little peek here.
Well, like we mentioned, bread and bread.
Has been bumped by power.
So on Thursday we'll be exploring the EN server for the very first time.
And also be aware that inside the back rooms in Advent on Friday is now at 4pm PT.
So it is two hours earlier than usual.
Don't be surprised, okay?
And I'm sitting on the middle chair so it's also two hours earlier than usual.
It's a bit earlier this week, okay?
Just remember, gotta be early.
Gotta be early, gotta be early, okay?
We'll make sure to be early and brief.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for the 72nd episode of FUWAMOCO Morning.
It was a good morning.
Good morning.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Meepo!
BAU BAU!
Eguizamu!
Pecho!
BAU BAU!
Viva!
Chuudon!
BAU BAU!
Den-den!
Me!
BAU BAU!
Snugglebeast!
Taboo Arrow!
BAU BAU!
Jelly Fall.
Sea to Moon.
BAU BAU!
Furu Furutsu.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!